e analcoliche
martana scuri già state lasciate corsa
ai giochi perché mi divertivo così detto
ciao ragazzi benvenuti in una puntata di
vita buttata oggi sono in compagnia di
due persone che permettono un
grandissimo esempio di vita le coliche
ragazza è bellissimo avervi qui è
bellissimo anche mentire quale fase
della vita del fatto che voi siate due
persone che secondo me servono dei
principi di vita io condivido e che non
riesco ancora a seguire in fondo nel tuo
caso le tue scelte etiche e morali nel
tuo caso il fatto che si è svegliato
l'altro ieri ok e se già sposato che
volevo pensarci mercato va in culo
[Musica]
ho notato che non ci piacciono quelli
quadrati
appena arrivata nel corso studio
dentistico a lavorare si presenta il
problema di omonimia quindi 2 francesca
sedute su due poltrone differiti
richiama il fratello di una delle due mi
dice di a mia sorella che mi hanno fatto
un incidente in auto e sto andando io
vedo io a prenderla per una delle due
francesca guarda poma fatto un incidente
ti preoccupare tutto fratello questa cui
scoppia a piangere e scappa via tempo
tre secondi esce l'altra francesca dallo
stesso mi accorgo che l'informazione
avrei dovuto darla legno tipo verdone
che è morto sempre meno della francesca
a cui ha dato la lega mi capitò anni
anni fa duo comico le ricordo ancora
sale e pepe vengono da me mi fanno anche
noi facciamo i video io li riconosco e
dico no vabbè se l'è pazzesco visto le
vostre parodie quello c'è lady car e lo
fa un ragazzo è una delle due mi fa
veramente solo io io ho sentito il mio
quarto e terzo secondo una
io lo sai che ho fatto il nome rimediare
ma the bees è ok scambiandoli prende
permise bis è ferma per i panthers a
quello che è sicuro e cambia sempre noi
per i gialli o cazzo e non ad effetto
non avere mai che ci siamo alla panda
così bene la bocca se speravo che mi
riesce di materiale che
dire tutto posso offrirti è stato quello
teorico vi faccio questo che
naturalmente ragazzo è dipinta certo
troverà
come nei film civile che lavori senti
e tutto quanto leandra
ti faccio un whisky sauer
ma senza la metà degli ingredienti voce
la caponata devo farlo on the rocks
kabul perché ho chiesto un whisky sour
solo perché adesso va molto di moda
nonché con lo senso album e io ho
chiesto senza perché mi sembrava un po
più dignitoso sabayon e
ghiaccio più grande ma fidatevi ragazzi
sono tipo ma noi alcuni quando parla
della benetton sentimentale la sta
parlando di cose più grandi di lorenzi
non sanno di cosa sto parlando no
manuela alcuni ha fatto la carabinieri
ha fatto anche una presentazione di un
libro di alfonso luigi marra
l'arcuri voi non avete mai visto questa
cosa mi prendo un secondo me lo
strategismo sentimentale
bellissimo ma tu non hai letto no c'è
stata questa intervista lei fissa il
vuoto come faceva in
carabinieri ho paura mi sento come
quando alle medie ti offrirà la prima
sigaretta
fare lo spirito di
[Musica]
una slittino
[Risate]
stati parlato di musica all inside job
ricavandola kakà cadavere del padre
dello scrittore diciamo che abbiamo e
analcolico quindi le coliche
uno spinotto interessante
sapeva certe volte in sei giorni
la mia figura di merda più grosso
insieme al mio ragazzo e una coppia di
nostri amici stavamo parlando le persone
che se la tirano perché fanno parte del
mondo dello spettacolo
allora io per portare diciamo un esempio
ho detto sì sai come questo o quel
fallito di di luca puntini puntini
non rendendomi conto che la persona che
aveva appena menzionato era il fratello
della ragazza viene in macchina con noi
io non so perché ma è lo stesso momento
nel quale rigo mi fa cagare il segno del
cancro
al seno del cancro
cagare
91 6 luglio sotto il segno del cancro i
siti di merda ma perché escono fatto
capisce
perché dovrei cocente leone che sei
centri ci sono ariete
leone e
sagittario
invece mio marito
gemelli bellissimo bellissimo non è la
questione di gusti gemelli pazzesco 12
soltanto usiamo gemelli pazzesco perché
è una persona
positivo in spareggio tra il gioco e tra
chi crede nell'astrologia che ormai solo
te a non far finta di credere
all'astrologia
doppia
noi ci mettiamo di parlarne anche tu
così propria lo stadio soggetto sia
e ci ospita vorrei condividere con voi
ultimo anno di liceo ultima
interrogazione di francese per
l'ammissione all'esame baudelaire le fer
de meyer ero talmente arguta che la
prima ora mio amico mi venne vicino a
grandi buongiorno ea rispondo contando
qui rispondo io perché io la si gioca
alle torrette e ogni tanto faccio
risposta scureggia non fa ridere non
puoi
allora yo yo yo vari tic vela che si
perderebbe ogni tanto magari controllo
quando giriamo sì per ogni tanto qualità
duris qui addominale ai miei tanti
picche magari facciamo colpo in canna
potrebbe
potrebbe partire è successo più volte
quindi questa cosa ne approfittano ma
anzi felicissimo poi il treno silenziosi
unito
le loro mogli stima dei decibel
altissimi ho imparato a fare una poker
face
la sua figlia così tra di noi solo
sguardo al terra che la gente diceva non
può averla fatta ieri per chi legge che
sono invece sono un maestro della black
mamba che si torna sentire un colpo di
katana nel mento e mercati
certo
però noi due abbiamo detto e come
forever tu mi piaci tu proprio proprio
le due hanno fatto
gianni morandi lui dieci ragazzi di
almeno 40 ci prova allergiche petardi
che si può bere e analcolico però ho un
gioco per voi ragazzi da parte una
flessione lunghissima e dungeon central
ha ricordato ha fatto da master a una
sessualità entrano nel mentre chris
roche dello sparo casa io sono la crisi
dei vostri pregi e difetti
pazzesco ragazzi del motivo per cui i
nostri genitori sono disperati io che
faccio spade laser e anche lui fa spalle
larghe ma giochiamo a un gioco e si può
fare solamente fra fratelli per cui io
farò entrare in campo il mio che
dovremmo fare un gioco di intesa che si
chiama password
[Musica]
io ho delle buste di consegna una
delle maggiori non fate leggere la
parola all'interno hanno
una sola parola dovrete fare indovinare
abbiamo la stessa città qual è la parola
contenuta all'interno della busta non
farmi vedere però culetto
pesca
a sbagliare di pietrino è comunque fu
eletto per andare a nino
cadrega
collegate che questi privati certo
giurino
verdino capito se intendi bisogna però
devono anche codice è capito no ma è una
chiacchiera primogeniti grazie
a
un verbo quindi secondo me
faccio in chiaro i fratelli colica ti
prego
[Musica]
tu io
male vegliano su di lui perché degli ogm
chissà cosa mi fa ritenere
io sono un ragazzo nello sri lanka tutto
tatuato
vale o non vale che lavori fare
male sì ma questo fa parte delle
competenze balzati della persona
ma è scritto in stampatello tipo di
scusa
grazie grazie
ai nisseni mesi
ma perché lui era contrario alle
simpaticamente della ragione dopo le
lacrime con le navi e medie di
master ha capito anche quella di prima
non mi dire anche la parola merda
incamerato loro bravissimi
doppio punto perché neanche sentito la
parola
musco reggiano bio
vegano
salamella beretta
[Musica]
insaccati
salame
l'ultimo budello
[Musica]
vado io ora non
partire rimarrà così
quando lo sappiamo nel settore ormai
più piccione
ascella dai
ala
ci sta a soffrire
solletico bravo
michael
attenzione però è che qui viene
tutto il
basket
jackson godendomi la parola sociale a
michael jackson nel 2002 non si può dire
margin due passanti abbiamo lanciato
thriller
[Musica]
due volte non vale a pagliaro è una
dov'era presente sul dizionario sul
simbolo su tre carri armati mentre
in cura fratelli scegliere
mi divertivo così da
però una nuova cosa c'è un calice di
vino dovevo rompere tra le mani e mi
creano diversi feriti
quello che anche le uomo quindi cambiano
se ti do uno in marrota lo non lo devo
rompere devo stringere le mani finché
non arriva il fuoco prima al punto del
punto di rottura cosa c'e dentro è
completamente pazzo
nel negozio dove lavoro 23 dicembre
siamo avvolti dal caos e dalla frenesia
in generale non contenti mettiamo anche
dopo altri articoli non passeranno a
ritirare i nostri clienti il mio caso
prima di passarlo in oggetto da mettere
da parte e mi guarda e mi fa mi amò la
presa alla sprovvista inizio a miagolare
peccato che non fosse un comando ma il
cognome della riunione che va da paura
la bara o composti tutti da non mi hanno
licenziato
immagini
ei
complimenti di tutti i mercoledì vedevo
questo vecchietto abbia del corso con il
suo classico cappellino in testa nel suo
classico bastone di legno intarsiato
solo sopra questo passo ne aveva montato
una trombetta da bce si divertiva a fare
gli agguati a tutte le coppiette contava
alle spalle una troupe ha spaventava e
poi correva via ridacchiando
sono molto invidiosa di questo
vecchietto perché probabilmente farò mai
una l'intenzione a volermi bulli alla
mia demenza senile con così tanta
leggerezza vediamo con gente strana con
i peccati navi rompe del mio essere
cancro mi porta a mangiare la patatina è
accaduta io sai che lo ha capito subito
perché tu possiamo 23 play del momento
in cui lui dice è tra questi nessuno se
li mangia e celine cura e stacco di
andare a mangiarli pensato come non ci
piacciono quelli quadrati
io non lo so di solito sono io la
persona strada in persona ma te ne rendi
conto di questa cosa che ne sono di
bosco range le versioni si allontanano
cos'è che paiono correggio in
continuazione raspaglia mischia nisco
molto la voce soprattutto durante i nove
idranti kiko tanti piccole verso
l'inizio non arrendersi si chiedono che
succede se sto bene se c'è qualcuno è
franata le domande altre
[Musica]
volte spiegare così grazie se no dicono
mille persone stanno affascinano molto
io mi annoio velocissimamente con
persone normali vece parlerei ore quella
gente un pochino più mi affascina
tantissimo ragazzi che a simili avesse
stati miei ospiti fine ti auguro
come starà sincera abbiamo anche un
abbraccio a tutti quanti malati di
turisti
e molto scorretta questa puntata ma allo
stesso tempo abbiamo la fortuna di avere
dei reperti che parlano di certi amici
creato imbarazzo tanti amici che è
soltanto amici con la sindrome di noi
abbiamo di tutta la famiglia la mostra
traccia lavoro
e possiamo dirlo perché abbiamo napoli
nel sangue guardavo
quando ci piace la pizza ed è con questo
che salutiamo e ringraziamo le coliche
ragnatele bravi la lista è lunghissima
noi ci vediamo non so quando ma sempre
su questo canale grazie per le
informazioni si pensa che questa cosa di
cattivo gusto che appena adesso sei
stato bravo fino alla fine e ha rovinato
tutto ciao ragazzi
[Musica]